[Applause]
when most people come and visit the
grand canyon they'll see maybe a couple
of points along the rim which are
amazing viewing points
but it's very hard to appreciate just
how extensive this place is
and realize just how much diversity of
life there is here like the incredible
mountain lion population
these mountain lions they've never been
filmed before so
how do you film a ghost
[Music]
so you're trying to capture the most
elusive predator in north america where
do you even start it's a bit like
solving a mystery honestly and we
started with surveillance and you look
down and you can actually see game
tracks coming along even below me here
now the fun begins and we descend deep
into the canyon
we set up a network of trail cams
basically setting up spies in the woods
to see what was going on skunk
javelina
no mountain lions yet
so national geographic wanted us to tell
a story about how these cats are using
the rim and using the landscape on the
grand canyon let's see what we got you
have to piece together the puzzle about
their movements and activity there's
been some absolutely gigantic rats here
but no mountain lions so far not today
we haven't had any luck so far
to be honest from the outset we were not
even sure if this was possible
and then we had a clip on one of our
trail cams of this big male mountain
lion walking into frame and and he just
stops and pauses and looks out for like
a minute it was everything that we could
have hoped for and started to feel like
we were ready to actually start filming
these cats and shooting really high
quality footage which was the next big
step
we are live we're running
the approach that we decided on was
camera trapping
camera traps allow us to film elusive
animals and just rare behavior that's
impossible to witness in person
just found some mountain on trucks with
camera traps you actually are using your
knowledge about that animal's behavior
and that ecosystem to basically
visualize the future in advance
to the finest detail on this particular
site where it's about as complex as it
gets meaning when a cat comes you know
and steps in one of these entry points
that we have visualize in advance or
predicted all 10 of these cameras will
start recording simultaneously
we currently have about 30 camera traps
running so
maintaining 30 camera traps just on a
day-to-day basis is a huge challenge and
then when you throw a foot of snow in
the mix it was an exciting challenge and
we both embraced it so we're about to
check these cameras for the first time
fingers crossed that we got something
exciting
since we had this big snowstorm we
haven't checked them yet
one
no
yes right over the log
wow
super cool it pauses
that's awesome i love that
i think my hope for mountain lions here
in the grand canyon is that they become
recognized as part of this iconic
landscape
there it is it's actually a really
different angle as well this one
it's a lot wider and you get this raven
flies up in the background as it's
coming past i hope that these images
will just really strike a chord with
people
a mountain lion the canyon's most
elusive resident
true hero of the great american west
[Music]